I'm fully into free diving and spear
fishing oh I've been and that that's
where I've found the love for a while
that's something I'd pretend to like if
a guy was hot I'm like I love spear
fishing
I think about all the time
the amount of things like pretended to
like for guys I always say I still don't
even know how I truly feel about magic
because everything
ever dated has had such a strong feeling
either hating it or loving it and I
always am switching it up like wait did
you say Free Falling free diving free
diving that's kind of thing I'd like do
you want a free dive and I'm like I'm so
spontaneously
hurt your toe right before you're like
oh my God this is so weird I should
check this I'll be in the van
foreign